Now that you have some experience
presenting off the shelf
view controllers,
you're probably wondering how to present
your own custom view controllers.
Here we have an app that
simulates rolling dice.
The first view controller with
the roll the dice button,
presents a second view controller
that displays a roll of the dice.
The second view controller can be
presented in the same way as the camera
roll or the activity views and
alert views.
But this time we have full control
over the displayed view controller.
The app is currently incomplete.
In a second, you'll be asked to download
it, and look at the Xcode project.
But before we get into the Xcode files,
let's pause for a second,
to draw the object diagrams for
the two view controllers.
That way we can clarify
which IBoutlets and
IBActions the project should contain.
The first view controller is simple.
It's just a single button
with a single action.
This is the action that should
trigger the presentation
of the Dice View Controller.
The Dice View Controller
is slightly more complex.
It needs outlets to these two
image views that are for the dice.
It also has one button
with a single action.
This action will cause the view
controller to be dismissed.
If you look in the instructor notes
you should see a file called dice.zip.
Go ahead and download that file and
then examine the Dice Xcode Project
with the following questions in mind.
Check off each question
as you find the answers.